[Music]
video three
housing
[Music]
this video is part of a series developed
for the sustainable wildlife management
program
to provide guidance for a successful
family poultry production
it focuses on small extensive and
extensive scavenging systems
but could also be useful for
semi-intensive production systems
[Music]
there are many reasons why poultry
should have a house
including protection from rough weather
thieves and predators such as dogs cats
snakes and birds of prey
housebirds are easier to catch to
inspect for signs of illness or injury
or to vaccinate against diseases
it is also easier to collect the litter
and waste
[Music]
of a good poultry house
some characteristics of a good poultry
house include being rain proof and
capable of protecting birds from the
direct sunlight strong winds and floods
good ventilation is important which is
affected by the windows the orientation
of the house and height of the ceiling
openings can be covered with wire mesh
to allow for good airflow while
preventing predators from entering the
poultry house
you should also be able to lock the
house securely
ease of access helps with the day-to-day
management and cleaning
[Music]
if constructing a new poultry house
plan ahead and think about the potential
flock size now and in the coming years
the size will depend on the number type
and ages of the birds and the production
system
will your birds be confined in the house
all day
or will they use the house at night only
for 10 to 15 adult birds the size of the
house should be about 2 meters squared
for a bigger flock of fully confined
broilers of about 2.5 kilograms each
a 1 meter squared poultry house per 10
to 12 chickens is recommended
for example if the house is 5 meters by
5 meters
this corresponds to 25 meters squared of
living space for 250 to 300 chickens
however this number can vary depending
on the season
less space is necessary in the cold
season
and the age and weight of the chicken
if the poultry house is too small
especially in intensified systems
several problems can develop
including unequal distribution of food
increased temperature
and chickens biting each other
[Music]
you can also build an enclosure around
your poultry house to limit the
wandering of the birds
but you would have to make sure that the
chickens always have a sufficient
quantity and diversity of food
this open air fence space is typically
25 meters squared or more
typically 10 times the size of the
poultry house and is called a chicken
run
this is an example of a poultry house
with a chicken run developed for the
sustainable wildlife management program
in madagascar
poultry houses feeder
basket for small cheeks
powder tray
sand ash antiparasitic
perch
nesting box hatchery
litter
types of poultry houses and their
materials
different types of poultry houses are
made from different materials
which vary widely from simply housing a
few birds for extensive systems
to housing many birds for semi-intensive
to intensive production systems
if you own less than 10 birds
a mobile house or a night basket placed
in a quiet and dry place can be
sufficient
an adequate shelter can be constructed
from materials available locally
including used or discarded construction
material
some commonly used materials are bamboo
wood reeds wire mesh thatched grass and
clay and cement bricks
always remove the bark from the wood you
use in order to prevent parasites from
hiding behind it
to prevent the spread of disease from
chicken droppings
select either an easy to clean solid
flooring or a slatted floor for example
made of wooden slats or bamboo sticks
any crack or hole in the house should be
immediately repaired
poultry house location
location must be considered when
building a house for chickens
for better management of the birds it is
recommended that the house be
constructed close to the homestead
so that you can hear if something is
happening at night
but at least 25 meters from other
poultry houses to avoid the spread of
diseases
the house should be constructed on a
well-leveled and well-drained ground
or can be elevated from the ground if
floods are frequent
elevated houses are also useful to
protect birds from predators
[Music]
it is wise to have the enclosure close
to trees for shade as well as close to a
clean source of drinking water for both
hydrating the birds and cleaning
utensils
such as the feeders and drinkers
around the house maintain the grass cut
low to keep snakes and rats away from
the chicken
[Applause]
[Music]
equipment
maintaining clean nests and locating
them in safe places
assists in controlling and improving
productivity
the quality of eggs is better if they
are clean
moreover it is easier to find eggs if
nests are provided rather than allowing
birds to lay eggs in hidden locations
you should provide at least one nest for
five adult birds
[Music]
roosting on perches will minimize the
contact between the birds and their
droppings
and therefore help to prevent diseases
perches are best made of bamboo or round
sticks that should match the size of the
bird's feet
20 centimeters of perch space per bird
is recommended
which corresponds to a one meter perch
for five birds
removable perches and nests will ease
the cleaning of the poultry house
[Music]
legislation
depending on your country or region
it is likely that for semi-intensive or
intensive systems
some specific legislation has to be
followed
for example
it may include farm registration
reporting of diseases or the requirement
that the location of these activities be
far from residential areas to reduce the
potential nuisance cost to the residents
by bad odors
contact your local administration to
learn about the rules that apply to your
situation
take home messages
when constructing a poultry house plan
ahead and think about the potential
flock size now and in the coming years
the poultry house should be roomy dry
airy and easy to clean
use cheap locally available materials
such as bamboo wood reeds
thatch grass or clay bricks
place the house close to your homestead
and close to a clean source of drinking
water
include enough perches and nests
preferably removable
[Music]
you